here's what would happen if you fell  into a piranha pool we think of piranhas  as those bloodthirsty fish that will  attack and kill anything on site but if  you happen to fall into a pool with them  chances are they'd actually be scared of  you that's because these fish are  relatively calm and the things they do  attack are typically smaller than them  and even if these things were starving  you'd most likely only end up getting  nipped a couple of times so naturally  they wouldn't attack but let's say they  somehow did would it be bad news for you  definitely relative to its size a  piranha's bite is more powerful than a  shark's and if a school of piranhas  attacked you roughly 400 of them could  turn you into a skeleton in just five  minutes  although it's unlikely that they would  attack and kill you  i'd stay away from these things  so